Speaker 1: So we're continuing to see a sort
of fracturing or a balkanization for lack
of a better term of the Republican Party.
And I mentioned this earlier, and I want to
spend a little more time on it now. You always
used to sort of have three wings of the Republican
Party. You've got that pro-business low tax
swing that may have been socially conservative,
but they didn't really care too much about
the social issues exemplified by people sort
of like Mitt Romney, although Romney as a
Mormon also seems to be a social conservative,
but maybe less so than some of the others.
But it's the pro-business low tax wing you
then had the libertarian right, so called
the pro liberty wing of the Republican Party,
exemplified by people like Rand Paul and others
of that ilk. And then you had the more extreme
evangelical religious right of the party,
which was exemplified by folks like I don't
even know, you know, Louie Gohmert, Ted Cruz,
people like that, where they may have had
conservative economics beliefs, but really
their worldview was informed along the lines
of social issues and by religion. Trump ism
caused a sort of realignment in which the
simplified factions became pro Trump Republicans
and anti Trump Republicans, at least during
the Trump era. And you had pro Trump Republicans
from all three of those factions and. Anti
Trump Republicans from all three of those
factions as well, sometimes it was less about
anti Trump, but just kind of like Trump's
skeptical or Trump agnostic in some sense,
we are now seeing the pro Trump side further
fracture into people who are pro Trump, but
realize that the cartoons of the party like
Matt Gates, Marjorie Taylor Green, Lauren
Bobert, these are bad for them. And then you've
got the pro Trump people doubling down and
supporting the gates and the Marjorie Taylor
Greens and these types of people. This weekend
there was an event that I guess was part of
the America First tour at which Matt Gates
spoke and Marjorie Taylor Green spoke. And
not only are the events themselves absolutely
insane, the interviews with the attendees
are even more outrageous. This took place
at the villages in Florida, a real Trumpy,
an enclave. So first off, without even getting
into the substance, it's a crowded room with
Matt Gates, signs with Queens. We are the
champions blaring. I can't imagine Queen as
a band or any of the band members would find
any common cause politically with these clowns.
I'm not even playing the audio because of
copyright reasons. OK, so the whole setup
is crazy. Then Marjorie Taylor Greene speaks
and she is still going on about the so-called
perfect Trump phone call
Speaker 6: because the Democrats impeached
President Trump over a perfect phone call.
By the way,
Speaker 1: these are parodies of themselves
at this point. A skit of what such an event
would look like would be no different than
the actual event. Matt Gates then portrays
the entire FBI investigation into his possible
child sex trafficking. As nothing but a politically
motivated witch hunt, which ignores that the
investigation started when Donald Trump was
president, and then he actually praises the
completely discredited Project Veritas like
any whatever crazy thing you imagine they
could say, they said all of it at this event.
Speaker 4: We have a right to confront our
accusers in this country. How about that?
There can be no due process here. If the only
process due to conservatives is to see leaks
embroidered on to lies, then just endlessly
repeated by the America last media. I hope
you guys show the thousand people outside
that wanted to be in here to hear this message,
but there are sometimes exceptional journalists
who turn the cameras onto the liars. And in
that vein, let me say thank God for Project
Veritas.
Speaker 1: So there is no reason. There is
no common sense. There is none of it to be
found anywhere here. And as you can probably
tell, it is not exactly an event with deep
political theory presented or philosophical
thought or anything like it. For me, the best
part is the interviews with the attendees.
Listen to this interview with a couple outside
the event.
Speaker 4: You guys both genuinely believe
the election was stolen. Yes. I mean, that's
you know, if you believe that that's true,
that is that horrible. Yeah. Yeah, I know
this is horrible that we would even be in
the situation to even think that, but it's
false. No, it's not. Why would they have all
those ballots hidden under tables? Why did
that man drive that truck all the way across
state lines,
Speaker 1: all of those ballots under the
table? Why did that man drive across state
lines? What? Why? And the reporter tries telling
them this stuff has been debunked. It makes
no difference. Take a look
Speaker 4: at the ballots under table thing
with Giuliani and Georgia. That's all been
proven to be false. It has not. I watched
it on TV.
Speaker 1: Listen, that's that's pretty water
tight. You know, she saw it all on TV. That's
all there is to it. And of course, where on
TV is the relevant question. Was it on Newsmax
before Newsmax got the lawsuit threats and
had to apologize and take back a lot of what
they said? Was it on Fox News's Lou Dobbs
Show before he had to apologize and ultimately
was kicked off the air for the constant propaganda,
debunked propaganda that was being spread?
We don't know where on TV she saw it, but
we've got some pretty good guesses. You know,
I I saw Mr. Ed on TV. I believe horses can
talk. Changed my mind. It's right there. You
can see it. How does this all get dealt with
at a systemic level? That's the question I've
been asking for some time. And I don't know
the answer. I don't know the answer. But it
is really bad. And I these people vote. It's
their right. I'm not suggesting we take that
right away. We just have to understand the
reality that many of these people vote. Some
don't, but many do